and then i saw a dream of myself in a
church
and i've never been to a church and
i started to see that i'm
worshiping in the name of jesus
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatu brothers and sisters and dear
friends
hope you guys are well inshallah welcome
to this video
now this video is going to be a bit of a
different one
you know and i want you guys to really
hear me out yeah before judging and
jumping to
all kinds of assumptions and stuff like
that
so this is what i'm
going to say inshallah somebody
told me to go home
and try to pray in the name
of god and for him to reveal himself to
me
so i went home and
i i tried it and then i saw a dream of
myself
in a church and i've never been to a
church
and i started to see that i'm worshiping
in the name of jesus
and this stream made me realize that
this is
a sign from god
this is exactly what the following video
a muslim woman claimed that happened yes
now i know i know i know clickbait you
guys get
hold of a second hold on a second we're
gonna watch the video
imagine i wake up and imagine
that because of that dream i changed my
entire way of life
a lot of not a lot of some people you
know these stories that you see on
youtube that claim
this yeah and i'm going to play you a
very video of so-called
a muslim sister but we're just going to
see how much
she was a muslim in that context you're
going to hear it for yourself here
and she becomes a christian
because of this dream that she had let's
listen with ourselves
yeah and let's ask ourselves a question
it's very important i want christians
and muslims to really really watch this
because we hear this a lot a lot of
christians even those who
you know there's some some fake one a
lot of fake ones out there like oh yeah
i saw jesus they reveal themselves to me
etc you know you hear this a lot from
christians as well like born christians
born again christians as well yeah
that they will come and say you know
jesus came to my life i saw him he
changed making move
constantly we need to learn a lesson
from this why
does all of them come with the same
thing and what does it
mean does it have any weight this is a
video of a sister now
i'm going to try to um my best to
minimize the video
because i believe they have kind of
beautified their self
a bit too much so i'm going to abstain
we're going to listen brothers please
abstain from looking it's a reminder to
myself
as well first i'm going to listen as
well each other i just need to look to
obviously to play
i'm not looking at her but just to play
screen okay here we go guys yeah this is
the story
of this such as kurdish iraqi kurt i'm
turkish good let's hear her story
started hanging out more and we did our
nightly newscast together no way there's
so many archive
videos okay i'm gonna have to pull one
for this we're gonna have to like slip
with it insert video of saz and steve
thanks for joining us on nttv nightly
news i'm steve hendricks and i'm suzanne
barzani
now yours is crazy i was in my car in in
college it was one night steven i would
just talk for hours you know he's my
friend
and i was just telling him all about my
breakup with this guy and he just he
felt so sorry for me and he was like you
know
he's like you just seem so hurt like you
have so many questions he's like you
know you told me that you've been
praying every night since you were a kid
who were you praying to and i was like
what does that even mean i was like i'm
praying to god
and wow when you're praying who are you
talking to and i was like well since i
was a kid i've been doing the
you know the muslim chant that you know
we say because you're right yeah you're
right
you know there's anything that you say
it's called
it's called what it's called one second
i just need to rewind a little bit back
to you guys one second once it wasn't
just a little bit but here we go here we
go
wait because you're right you're right
you know there's something that you say
it's called
it's that night you pray and this is
something you say
that's a shahada that's not a prayer and
you do that when
you know you're you know when someone
comes to islam
or for example if somebody's on the
verge of dying oh
maybe in salah but she's talking about
prayer so let's carry on
i would do it and you know and then i
would speak my prayer and kurdish and
everything but it was always the same
every night so he said
when you go home tonight he's like and i
really trusted him he was like you know
when you go home tonight he's like why
don't you just
just pray how you just would talk to me
for example or talk to a friend just say
like hey guys who are you reveal
yourself to me
um and just make it clear through my
dreams because my dreams are just i have
a spiritual gift in my i can just
tell so many things are coming with like
through my dreams
devil's deception one of the way devil
gets you makes you have some kind of a
trust or sixth sense our family members
will come and say
my sixth sense is so strong you know my
dreams you came to this false
hope and then you think like that's
something to be trusted with no i trust
my instincts
your instincts can be wrong you're not
infallible it can be wrong
let's let's carry on guys let's carry on
here here we go so i was like okay fine
i was at that point so depressed and
desperate you're looking at you're dead
you're like god gave me something so i
was like okay fine and so i went home
that night and i kid you not like as i'm
getting ready for bed and i'm getting
ready to pray that was the first time
since i was eight years old where i
didn't do it i didn't pray to muhammad i
didn't pray it anyway i just
prayed to muhammad we don't pray to
muhammad do you
get what i'm trying to say i'm not
trying to mock i'm just trying to say
there's some
holes there in the story but let's carry
here right in my in my voice and i said
hey god what's up like
who are you yeah reveal yourself to me
and that night i literally had a dream
that i was in a church or
worshiping jesus's name had you ever
been in a church i had never been in a
church i didn't even know what really
meant but i was like both of my hands
were raised in this dream and i was
amongst a crowd of just people in a
church oh my god and i was just
worshiping jesus name and i was like oh
my gosh i woke up the next day and i
told stevie and he was just so
like he was shocked i mean he wasn't
expecting that either but he was just
like wow
and then for like two weeks straight
after that shay my dreams i was getting
to know jesus through my dreams
yeah the rest is history that's so
amazing and i just love how god speaks
to everyone a different
okay listen carefully in this bit yeah
she gives a disclaimer of how practicing
her family was yeah
like ethnically culturally we were
muslim did that mean that we were
praying
several times a day and fasting during
ramadan and things like that no we
weren't
so she's making it very clear as a
family culturally muslim
never practicing um and now
let's just get straight to the crop of
the mouth guys
truth truth is not something that can be
measured
by subjective personal experiences
there are people who have had mass
visions mass
visions there are people who may
go and see a certain religious figure in
their life
a lot of muslims get caught up with this
seeing that you know
a certain very high vision and he's like
yeah you know i'm gonna under their
judgment i'm gonna answer
i don't know the questions in the grave
all kinds of stuff some muslims fall for
this so let's just make it very clear
now just imagine guys firstly we
understand that the sister was not clued
about
her religion at all
and she admits herself yeah okay so it's
not video to mock her we're just trying
to get somewhere
guys you do not choose a way of life
based on and a lot of christians reject
islam why because it doesn't suit their
lifestyle today
yeah there's a lot of people who come to
islam for christians don't get twisted a
lot
yeah especially females the point is
this that
because it doesn't fit in their
lifestyle so the thing is now
it's they live a lifestyle of just you
know jesus paid for their sins so they
just
do whatever you like today people going
to church it's like they're going to a
nightclub
there is no value left if jesus was here
today brother it would be
it'd be peak for you it would be for you
so the thing is now
they have totally disregarded their
religion so much so to me it seems
that once again people like a religion
that suits their lifestyle
and that is insincerity and allah says
he knows the hearts
so if you stand in front of along the
day of judgment let's say allah okay
why do you become a christian i had a
dream
okay what was the dream i was in a
church okay
and i prayed in the name of jesus all
right and then you saw a couple more
dreams yep jesus revealed himself to et
cetera
how does that prove that that very
concept that that sp
and a subjective personal experience is
correct
how you have satan worship saying i saw
satan in the dream he said bro
man's on her follow me yes blood walk
one let's go
so the thing is if you think about it
how do you make a life decision
your soul putting your soul at risk
such a life-changing moment if you are
genuinely looking for the truth
you would not make a decision based on
dreams if i saw jesus in my dream
and if jesus in my dream by the way this
figure
said to me that i am god i'll say to him
i would be like
i might go for a little hook why because
i know it's falsehood
even in today america's studies were
done nearly i can't remember the exact
figures yet
sixty percent of some of those numbers
of americans who were christian the
bible bill
they don't believe jesus to be good it's
an innate disposition of a fitra
yeah they don't believe that it doesn't
make sense that's why
christianity biggest downfall in the
western world is this whole concept of
divine jesus being divine etc
you see people they find it problematic
even one christian school i can't
remember his name he said
he said the one of the laughing stocks
to the muhammadans would become a
laughingstock because of this whole
belief that jesus is god
it doesn't make sense it doesn't add up
you do not determine truth
based on oh it makes me feel good oh
it's just my lifestyle
oh i had a dream you don't you don't
pick
truths like that and if you do it shows
i'm so sorry
i'll be very bluntly straight to the
point it shows that
you just want to believe what you want
to believe
or what sounds good to the ear jesus
died from our sins
whoa yes hallelujah
that's it and by the way please guys i'm
not trying to mock please forgive me for
i'm not trying to come across that day
i'm not trying to respectful
but i'm saying it doesn't make sense
it's the same as a muslim coming and
saying
i saw this beer sab you know this
religious guy in my dream
calm down relax yourself man what's
wrong with you you need rookia what's
wrong
calm down you can't make that a reason
and be like oh here's the truth
we have muslims claiming certain things
as well don't get it twisted
so guys this video was done share with
your friends and family because we hear
this a lot and the question that nistii
asks is the following
this question devil's deception how do
you know and it's a question i asked
christians
how do you know that it's not satan
how do you know how do you know
satan's first thing that he wants you to
do is to worship other than god
the one the second commandment thou
shalt not worship any other god
besides the lord god god not jesus god
and he's coming to you in the dream and
telling you hey i'm god in my name and
you
yeah okay wow sorry dream and you make
such a big life decision
and i'm sorry once again if one is
sincere
they would never ever do that and i'm
gonna know there's no problem sisters
whatever religion you follow you should
follow it based on this hack the truth
yeah islam when i was looking into islam
my dad
hated it my family hated it yeah
not all yeah it was being like this
whole attacks happened islam was one
religion that it was just like bruh if
you've got any religion that's not the
one
especially with the stuff that says
about women etc but when i
studied it for about three years and i
said this is the truth
how could i lie to myself how could i
look in the mirror and lie to myself and
say no why
because it's uh because it's it's
connected to terrorism
because of women's rights et cetera all
this kind of stuff
um and um because it's being attacked
and
i don't care if the entire globe is
against something and that is the truth
and the ha
like the self said the haqq even if it's
one person it's the haqq
guys i'll end on this not inshallah and
may allah subhanahu ta'ala protect
us and guide us and not make us fall for
these petty
dreams and make us make life decisions
that's going to jeopardize our very
soul till next time